great really great questions during the
break so appreciate that Thanks so this
morning we started off with you know how
airplanes fly and we talked Philip
talked you through the aircraft systems
and you know what what's going on inside
an airplane that's helping that airplane
function this afternoon we're really
going to focus on navigation so we're
going to talk about charts and airspace
and we're going to talk about the flight
environment and and how you navigate
through it so let's get started with
charts and airspace so aeronautical
charts they kind of help you out with
where you're going so there are actually
a number of electronic charts so there
are a couple websites so sky vector comm
is a great website that shows these
these charts there's a search bar so you
can type in an airport for example and
it'll zoom right in to that chart you
can also get some apps and I'm gonna
pass around my iPad
there is a program called for flight so
how many people have used for flight
before so just a handful of you so you
know there are a lot of different
software and an Garmin has has a great
software too not really recommending any
over the other but this has just happens
to be on my my iPad I take this with me
when I go flying and so I have the app
pulled up so you can basically move
around and look at the the map and then
I have a physical map that'll also pass
around
which is this particular map is a VFR
sectional map so VFR is for visual
flight rules as opposed to IFR which is
instrument flight rules and we'll have a
whole whole talk just on instrument
flight rules later but for now when you
start flying you start with visual
flight rules which means that you you
can look outside the airplane there are
no clouds obscuring your view and so
this is a very giant and unwieldy
document to have in your plane while
you're flying and so this is why I don't
carry this in the plane and I instead
carry the iPad but this this sectional
they're actually different parts across
the US where there are very busy areas
with lots of airports and so they have
these sectional maps so a section of the
United States and you can look look at
those and so I'm going to pass this
around and the as we talk through the
slides which zoom into various parts of
this for you to take a look at
okay so the I think the most important
part of the sectional chart is the
legend and it basically answers all the
questions that you're gonna get on your
exam about it we just help ask you what
all of these different doohickeys are so
we'll zoom into a particular part so
this is about an airport so there's a
lot of different data contain and it can
be a little bit overwhelming so when you
when you look at that that chunk of text
and data you really can just look at a
sectional charts legend to tell you what
all of that means so so this is the the
chunk of text numbers and letters that
you would see on a sectional chart and
then over here it explains what they are
so you can see what each thing is so so
ADIS over here which it's nicely defined
over here so you don't have to memorize
anything automatic terminal information
service the ATIS which is what provides
weather information we'll have a whole
talk just about weather information and
radar coms and air traffic control but
you can see here that there's a
frequency one twenty three point eight
so that's telling you that in order to
get the weather information for that
particular Airport you turn to the
frequency one twenty three point eight
and you can hear what the weather is
there's a lot of other data data on here
so for example it tells you some autumn
automated surface weather or a sauce one
35.42 so you know that you can contact
that frequency if you want to get the
automated weather service so a lot of
this this data is listed there so we
won't go through everything because it
is nicely defined in the legend another
area we'll focus on or just what what do
airports look like so over here is the
part of the sectional that has Boston
Logan Airport so you see all these you
know lines that are outlined in blue so
if you look over at the
legend it describes exactly what that
means so having having these lines
outlined in blue hard-surfaced
runways greater than you know 8,000 feet
and so it showed it just tells you
exactly what that information is and
smaller airports with shorter runways
have these circles with lines and the
lines are generally trying to depict the
runway and the so the line here will
generally be aligned with what the
direction of the runway is and when
there are two lines that generally is
representing two runways so this down
here in the bottom right corner is a
Hanscom or bedford and so you can see
the two crossing runways here depicted
here so continuing along there are also
abandoned airports
so the actual airport has an X on it and
then you'll also see this X through the
circle to represent that it's an
abandoned place so it still might be a
good option if there's an emergency and
you're really looking for a place to
land but it's not a good idea if you
have the ability to get to a functioning
open airport where you know the runway
is clear other information that is
provided in these charts and sectionals
or whether or not fuel is available and
what are the operating times of the
tower because all that information
changes very frequently those sectional
charts have to be updated so that
particular sectional that I'm passing
around is out-of-date they get out of
date very quickly for for flight you can
download constantly download new apps
new maps so before you fly you kind of
download everything and it refreshes and
then you have it good to go another
thing that a sectional chart is really
good for is identifying obstacles so
these are the kind of descriptions of a
tower for example or more than one a
group of instructive obstructions and so
it kind of tells you that there's an
obstruction so in the bottom right
corner we see
there's a there's an obstruction right
here with this little triangle and then
it has two numbers so it has 796 and
then it has parenthesis 335 now it
explains in words what that means so the
top number is the elevation above the
mean sea level and then the the one in
parentheses is the height above ground
now the way I like to remember it it's a
little bit morbid but it really helps
you remember it is the number on top is
the out is the altitude that will be
indicated on your altimeter if you hit
the top of the obstacle and then the
number in parentheses is how far you'll
fall to hit the ground so that's a good
way of remembering what those two
numbers are and what's the difference so
any questions about sectional charts
before I move on to airspace
yes yes so the question was about blue
versus red outlines that's in fact
answered directly by different types of
airspace so it's a great transition so
I'll move straight into that so there
are different types of airspace and they
are labeled with these letters so in
aviation speak just to make sure we're
being clear instead of saying B we say
Bravo right because we don't want to get
confused you say B or C or D so you say
Bravo so we have these different types
of airspace so uncontrolled airspace is
Class G or class of golf and then you
have the controlled airspace so Class A
Class bravo class charlie etc and then
there's some special use airspace so the
the short answer is the different colors
of blue and purple represent different
types of airspace as well at different
different classes of airspace and can
represent whether you're close to
certain types of airports so the way to
think about airspace although you see
now there's a lot going on in this map I
agree with you but they're a bunch of
they're a bunch of circles that are
going on well one thing to keep in mind
is that you
Circle is actually operating at a
particular elevation and so one way to
think about it is that airspace is
three-dimensional and a lot of people
think about it as a as a wedding cake as
an upside-down wedding cake and the
reason they think about it that way is
that usually around a particular airport
like Boston Logan Airport there is a
restricted airspace right they don't
want you to just fly through because you
could you know interfere with commercial
traffic that's landing there so they
they want you to have certain
restrictions when you're close to an
airport so the reason it looks like an
upside-down wedding cake is that when
airplanes are being sequenced to come in
they're usually at pretty high altitudes
because they've been flying across the
country so their restrictions on the
airspace start high up so you can
actually fly underneath the class the
class Bravo airspace so if you if you're
flying on this side so we showed kind of
to the left you can be underneath the
class Bravo airspace and the the
restricted space can be above you but as
you get closer to the airport the
restricted airspace goes all the way
down to the ground right to the surface
so it touches the ground around the
airport because that's what the
airplanes are landing so that's why
there's it's like a layer of the wedding
cake that is lower and lower until it
touches the ground does that make sense
great okay so here's the specific answer
to the question you were talking about
there are all kinds of different lines
what do they mean so if you see a solid
blue line that represents class Bravo
airspace so that's like the airspace and
around Boston Logan Airport is class
Bravo
so you'll see a solid blue line and the
solid magenta line is class Charlie
airspace which is first usually a
slightly less busy airport we'll define
it in a moment
but you might have seen other lines
which are kind of these big fat kind of
faded lines lower down and so that
really depends it
it usually is denoting some form of
class II airspace and depending on where
it is it refers to different it isn't
affected different altitudes and we'll
dive into those minimums and
descriptions in just a moment so let's
start at the top at class a airspace so
this is very high up pretty much as a as
a private pilot in a single-engine
airplane you're never going to encounter
this class a airspace because it starts
at 18,000 feet so it's pretty high up so
pretty much all only Jets big jets
commercial jets fly at that altitude in
order to fly into that altitude you
actually have to have your instrument
flight rating and we're gonna have a
whole lecture devoted just to instrument
flight training but really what it means
is that you could be flying through
clouds where you can't see outside the
airplane to avoid other airplanes and
you're just relying on your instruments
it requires also a lot more precision
that you know when you say that you're
at 20,000 feet you have to be at 20,000
feet you can't drift off to 21,000 feet
you have to stay put and the reason is
that when you're flying instrument
you're relying on the air traffic
controllers to sequence you and so they
have multiple airplanes in the same
space and there they're basically
depending that you'll be able to hold
the altitude that they give you and the
heading that they give you and then it
might put another airplane relatively
close to you but they know that you can
both fly very well and accurately so
you're not going to hit each other so
they have all kinds of airplanes up in
the class alpha or class a airspace in
fact the pro tip is that most people
just call it Class A even though you're
supposed to say alpha we talked to
Philip talked a little bit about the
altimeter setting and how the actual
altimeter setting can vary from where
you are but didn't you have big jets
that are traveling very quickly and they
might cross multiple places with
different
altimeter settings in class a airspace
you actually have everybody using the
same altimeter setting 29.92 and that
way everybody is is viewing the same
altitude as the other person at the same
height so that everyone can make sure
not to hit each other and when everyone
when anyone is supposed to be at 18000
they're there at the same altitude as
the people around them okay
the next is class Bravo this is a lot
more relevant to something that you
might encounter so this is right around
over here it's right around Boston Logan
Airport
we heard meenakshi talk about her time
talking to JFK the kennedy tower right
around new york all of the busy airports
have class bravo so the way to remember
Bravo as Bravo is busiest to the busiest
airports or class Bravo there's you
actually have to have an explicit
clearance to enter someone has to say
you're cleared through the Bravo if they
don't tell you you're clear through the
Bravo you're not allowed to enter that
airspace you actually can't fly you know
even after you get your solo and you're
a student pilot you have to have a
specific endorsement again endorsement
is a signature by your instructor that
says you're allowed to enter that
particular airspace your aircraft also
requires specific equipment and in
particular it needs a mode C transponder
which basically helps to identify more
accurately where the aircraft is and
then we talked about this upside down
wedding cake so typically right in the
middle of the wedding cake right around
the airport it's from the surface to
10,000 feet but it goes out wider
starting at a higher altitude so right
here near Logan Airport for example
there are parts of it where the class
Bravo doesn't start until 3,000 feet so
if you fly at 2,500 feet you can fly
right underneath the class Bravo you
don't have to get clearance to fly there
and as and if you accidentally fly too
high and and you go through that 3000
foot barrier it's called busting the
Bravo and you're in big trouble and
don't do that okay so this is again
Boston Logan Airport is right in the
middle and then the Rings go
it showed the different rising altitudes
so how do you know what the altitude is
so right right in the center see it has
70 and then a line that says SFC so SFC
means surface so right in the center of
the circle it goes down to the surface
and then you see now the number change
to 20 so you can go up to 2,000 feet and
out here 30 so that means if you're at
3,000 3,000 feet up to 7,000 feet is
where the restriction is below 3,000
feet you're okay okay so now is class
charlie
so there are also busy airports but
they're not quite as busy as the class
Bravo Airport so for example Manchester
New Hampshire Providence Rhode Island
here you're required to establish
two-way radio communication where they
actually know the tail number of your
aircraft so every aircraft has a number
if it's a US aircraft it usually has an
N or November at the beginning so you
know November 5 3 5 you know alpha Bravo
and so you actually have to say what's
your tail number is so and then in this
example
8:08 whiskey Tango but if you just say
you know I'm an aircraft five miles to
the south they don't know you they
haven't identified you in particular so
that doesn't count as establishing the
two-way communication but once you have
established two-way communication with
the with the controller you can enter
without a specific clearance to enter
the class charlie airspace so here's a
an example of that so we have the
airport in the middle and now we have
magenta lines instead of blue lines
because it's a class charlie airspace
instead of class Bravo airspace
so class Delta one of the the airports
we've been talking about Hanscom also
known as bedford is a class delta
airport and so so here you have to
establish to a radio communication as
well it's it's indicated by a dashed
blue line so this is an example of
Worcester Airport and you can see the
dashed blue circle around the airport
okay now class Class E airspace is when
you start getting a little complicated
so it's not necessarily related to a
particular airport and it really applies
to just other controlled airspace around
and the the reason that they have this
airspace is to define certain weather
restrictions so how close and far you
can be from clouds what the visibility
needs to be in order for you to fly in
these environments so it can be
indicated in a lot of different ways it
gets very confusing so we have both
magenta blurry lines and and blue blurry
lines and the legend of course is your
friend it defines exactly what it means
and and why it's a different color and
you can see those throughout so
sometimes like when we were flying to
Bar Harbor as we talked about earlier
along the coastline you might see those
restrictions or around a small airport
so now let's zoom back out this big
picture you might see a whole bunch of
things going on on the sectionals that
are coming around the room it looks very
complicated but but now you kind of know
that the what the little dots mean you
also see some yellow the yellow
indicates a congested area so there
might be like dense population over
there so that's relevant because you're
not supposed to fly low over a congested
area but it's also helpful when you're
flying around to identify where you are
that okay I'm over a city versus them
over just some some fields there are
also Airways on those section
and maps being passed around which are
indicated by these kind of blue lines
with an arrow on it with a heading so
what I mean by heading is like it says
one three two degrees and so these these
Airways are our places that sometimes an
airplane gets told to follow a
particular airway might be the fastest
way to get from one place to another so
here's an example of an airway on the
sectional you can see these blue lines
kind of cutting across and then another
relatively confusing airspaces is this
classic Gulf airspace and it basically
is uncontrolled airspace you can do
whatever you want
you might see this over a desert you
won't see any of this in the Northeast
there are too many airports and too many
things going on but in the in the middle
of the country or in certain places that
are not as populated you'll see this
uncontrolled airspace and you can do
whatever you want so the memory aid here
is golf means go for it
so here's the summary so this is the
class Bravo is that upside down wedding
cake and then you get the class charlie
class Delta and then class year is kind
of everywhere that doesn't have other
restrictions and then class golf is
unrestricted now each of those types of
airspace so a B C D they all have some
specific requirements associated with
them so for example we talked about in
class a airspace you have to be
instrument-rated
in Class B airspace you might need to
get a class Bravo airspace you might
need to get a special endorsement to be
able to fly there then the entry
requirements so classic golf is go for
it you can fly in plastic golf airspace
without talking to anyone about anything
you just take off and you fly where as
we talked about for example class Bravo
where you need explicit clearance to
enter the airspace and then come all of
the the visibility or minimums as I
talked about these are prime candidates
for the FAA exam
they're just things you basically have
to have to remember so class a airspace
you already have to have an instrument
rating which means hey there can be
instrument conditions which means it can
be cloudy you could be flying in a cloud
so there's no specific visibility
requirement there could be zero
visibility and you could be flying so
that's why it says n/a for all of the
the class-a visibility but on the other
ones there are some more restrictions
and so they might you know want to you
know for example when you're in class
Bravo airspace you have to remain clear
of clouds the reason that they don't
have a more stringent restriction you
know that you have to be a thousand
miles away from a cloud is because
they're really watching everybody in
that airspace and moving them around so
they can they can generally make sure
that there isn't an airplane in a cloud
that's about to pop out and hit you
you're already aware of all the other
aircraft whereas when you have less
control and they're not air traffic
controllers necessarily talking to
everyone they want to give they want to
make you stay farther away from a cloud
because if you're in a cloud if you're
near a cloud you may not see an aircraft
it's on the other side of the cloud and
then you know you could have a collision
so there's also a fair amount of special
use airspace so there's their restricted
areas a lot of the restricted areas oh
yes go ahead
that's a great question how do you know
how far you are from a cloud there's no
good way to know you're just supposed to
guesstimate really by looking outside
the window and looking at the cloud if
you're near an airport and then you
might know what the runway length is so
you can use that to kind of gauge
distances but there isn't a there isn't
a hard and fast rule of knowing how far
you are from a cloud
well clear of clouds is really easy you
just don't go in the cloud there I would
say there's not a very good way of
knowing whether you're a thousand feet
or 2,000 feet away from a cloud in
general I use those as guidance that
okay I should I should basically stay as
far away from the clouds as possible so
if there's a cloud near me I'll I'll
turn off course whereas if it's just
clear of clouds I'm willing to come
right underneath that cloud good good
question
okay so restricted area so some
restricted areas restricted areas are
either hot or on or there or they're
cold and they're not active so you only
have to avoid a restricted area if it's
hot so if you're already in
communication with air traffic control
you can just ask them if a particular
restricted area is active or not there
are also some prohibited areas like over
presidents houses and then there are
temporary flight restrictions or TFRs
and they can be very complicated we'll
talk about a couple in particular so
around a stadium you're not supposed to
fly there around Disneyworld you're not
supposed to fly low over Disneyworld and
sometimes if the president is traveling
somewhere there'll be a temporary flight
restriction and might just it might not
tell you that it's the president might
just say you know a VIP is in the area
so you're not allowed to to fly and then
there's certain areas that you just have
to proceed with caution but you're
allowed to enter so alert areas military
operation areas and other warning areas
so you just want to be alert especially
alert when you're in those spaces and
then again you have a whole bunch more
blue and magenta lines that mean
different things that basically describe
all of the different types of
environments that we talked about so I
think the one you're most likely to
encounter is this one that's very close
to two Minuteman Airport so this is
really just west of Hanscom there's a
there's a small area there it's not
usually active but if it is it's one
that you want to keep an eye out and
then we talked about TFRs the temporary
flight restrictions there some that are
unpublished so over
stadiums or over football games
sometimes you won't see those published
in advance but in general it's a good
idea to be aware when you're going over
a stadium not to be too low over it
there are a lot of different resources
to dive in we already talked about
skyvector their Hut a bunch of different
options here and we're seeing that going
around just so I can see where it is who
has the iPad that made its way pretty
far and then the sectional I see over
there so we'll keep it passing around
all and all afternoon so just a couple
practice questions to keep us on our
toes which which statement about
longitude and latitude is true
okay so a B or C shout it out B all
right that's correct
one one rule I have a thumb that helps
me is that meaning of longitude versus
latitude which one goes in which
direction latitude is horizontal and I
think of latitude sounds like FATA
two-door being fat how your horizontal
so anyway longitude are the vertical
lines so they cross the equator at right
angles so I'll leave this to somebody
that has a sectional or has seen the
sectional let's see if you can answer
this question referring to one of those
legends oh that's great so in the back
we got another way of remembering
latitude so he said latitude sounds like
a ladder so it looks like steps of a
ladder so that's why they're horizontal
that's a great great idea Thanks yeah so
that was that
longitude goes the long way around
whereas latitude sometimes especially at
the poles is shorter good at very good
ones Thanks
so I'll ask the I guess the third of you
the the 30 or 40 or so of you who have
already seen the sectional to be the
ones to guess this one so a B or C C
alright good job very good so these you
know if you take a look at the the
legend on those maps for the rest of you
as it comes around it should be more
clear
you